Gary Gary yes let's let's bring it down
for a second to hold on yeah he's Gary
Gary give it all no not no not us yeah
no I kind of guaranteed you bro
listen listen you're bad guy Brian I'm a
bad guy all the guys at a club I
remember I never talked you to marry me
I hear some waitress passing kind of
says you were difficult at one point God
knows I came in what she said and I come
on the podcasting alright Gary Owen is
difficult and that is so good that I
heard you heard it he's a scared you
hurt and you were like what the [ __ ]
right and I was like I didn't mean
backpedal to apologize I've heard
nothing but great things about you and
and I want to say I want to say you
remember who said the bad thing about me
I don't remember her was it Brandi Brady
and Pittsburgh granted the same I want
to single mom single mom always got an
edge she said you struck her you struck
her and right open her banger banger as
well and then you took a [ __ ] in the
middle of the floor and said [ __ ] you
guys and you left so that would answer
the checks I guess we're difficult so
that's all I heard that's all I heard
that's all I heard other than that I
hear you're a fantastic guy I think if
we didn't tip he ordered like primary
taquitos all weekend that must have been
a sense yeah honestly when I first
started doing stand-up I had no concept
of tipping really I didn't realize means
hip your greenroom wait so when when I
held all you guys I was like this I bet
you this goes way back on tip and
greenroom waitress days weird it's
[ __ ] how much she was everything how
many I mean theame hundreds and hundred
thousand yeah knows that you've done and
then one waitress waitress had a bad day
and you ran out of millions well here's
the thing I threw a little bit of a
tantrum on my set the other day I felt
justified but I guarantee I guarantee
the people that didn't know what was
going on
looked at me and said that guy's a dick
all the rooms ready and so we've all had
these moments
even though I give a lot and I'm a
comedy juice you knew you are a bit of a
diva I could be a dick somebody knives
dick I just get mad I just I throw a
little tantrums but not at anybody but
you were a dick the last week of March
yeah not that I remember the day you
heard that
come on the pod cuz I'm sorry the
amazing thing is like you look at your
whole career like okay I think I've done
some decent things in my career and the
only time Bryan Callen ever brought me
up quiz yes you're difficult to work
with
I was bored taking back that we did a
movie together
I'm a bad person I'm a [ __ ] everything
guys ever gonna work with I go we didn't
say that on ride-alongs you were fine
that day you were a Marine though might
slay me maybe maybe still here I was
like the guy's a veteran the whole thing
was shitty III could have backtracked
more I coulda backpedaled more I did
tell them it's unlike you to go badly
it's always actually like really bad
it's but especially publicly I'm on a
podcast just I was just talking one
Monday with that guy yes I even carry
out like volatile that's he said yeah
he's Reval Atal that's even worse than I
remember by the way it's not what the
person said so I made that up I was like
he must have thought my character
ride-along was real oh my god took off
my clothes I'm a bad guy well like you
guys know we have you here now yeah yeah
I'm all the way from the quadrant ow man
yeah yeah Louis Vuitton bag guys right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]